(uneasy music)
- [Narrator] Russian tanks that cost
over a million dollars are being taken out
by cheap consumer-style drones,
like this one that cost
a few hundred dollars.
Since the Ukrainian
counteroffensive began,
military analysts say there's
been a dramatic increase
in Ukraine's use of FPV,
or first person view drones
with most Ukrainian
battalions using these drones
to execute kamikaze-style
attacks on Russian tanks,
troop positions, and
other large scale weapons.
The aim is twofold:
to make the military
less dependent on weapons
from western countries
and to operate cheaply.
(drone buzzing)
The Wall Street Journal
collected dozens of attack videos
from Ukrainian drone teams
and spoke to analysts
from Janes Intelligence
to break down how these
attacks were executed.
Kamikaze drones must get
very close to a target
and remain undetectable.
To execute an attack like
this, FPV drone pilots
work in teams to identify targets
and get into position to strike.
The team usually includes a driver
to get to the attack location
and two drone pilots,
one for the attack or kamikaze drone,
and one for a reconnaissance drone.
The optimal flight distance for missions
is roughly one to two miles to the target,
but they can launch from
as far as seven miles.
One way they evade detection
is by using low quality cameras on FPVs.
The signals these cameras transmit
are less likely to be scrambled
by Russian electronic warfare systems.
Before launching, the
operators attach explosives
to the kamikaze drone
with tape and hardware.
The attack drone operator wears
a virtual reality style
headset to control the drone.
(drone buzzing)
After launching, a reconnaissance drone
looks for the target.
In this footage from
the Zaporizhzhia region
near the city of Orikhiv,
it's a Russian truck.
Ukrainians targeted it
because it was carrying
ammunition to Russian troops.
The attack drone follows
the truck as it turns
and crashes into it
detonating its payload.
When striking a supply truck like this,
a drone pilot will aim for the
cabin to take out the driver.
The strategy is similar
when targeting tanks.
The most vulnerable spot on a tank
is its engine compartment
located here on the rear side.
Drone pilots often aim for them,
as in this attack from behind.
The drones strike the
weakest points on tanks
and heavy machinery like these
infantry fighting vehicles.
Here, the open hatch is a vulnerability
the pilot likely noticed.
The pilot appears to hit the turret
where some of the vehicles crew sit
and ammunition is stowed.
Here a kamikaze drone
strikes a Russian truck
that lays landmines.
On these trucks pilots
target the mine modules.
Deterring these trucks is key,
as minefields have been a major obstacle
in Ukraine's fight to regain territory.
The failure rate of missions can be high,
according to Ukrainian units we spoke to.
Russian firepower can knock these drones
out of the sky if discovered,
as shown by this near miss.
About 100 Ukrainian
companies manufacture FPVs,
40 of which receive government contracts.
Most of the parts these
companies use come from China
and are becoming difficult to source.
Ukraine's use of these DIY style weapons
is rapidly evolving, and
now Russia is catching up.
(drone buzzing)